you have the bipartisan support to ban
tick tock not do some half-baked bill
that's going to give Democrats more
power to mess around with other people's
rights but to ban Tick-Tock outright do
you believe that's going to ultimately
pass in that form
yeah if you watch what I've said yes it
will we've already had the hearing to
start the process and the legislative
process to make that happen you know
we've been in office less than a hundred
days but watch what we've been already
able to accomplish and bring forth
I know but the one thing we do is we
play by the rules and we bring It
Forward just as the way it's able to
accomplish all right Mr Speaker voter
enthusiasm it's a it's obviously very
important going into this election cycle
so even though Republicans did take the
house last year's midterms were
considered by a lot of people to be
underwhelming particularly considered
considering what's happened since Biden
took office to our economy this
Wisconsin Supreme Court election was a
big loss this week in fact the map shows
it further moving to the left since 2020
the state of Wisconsin is that
concerning and what is the GOP doing to
counter what is a very aggressive move
by the Democrats to Brand the Republican
party as anti-democracy anti-women
Etc
you know this is very scary from a
number of positions because here they
were campaigning for a position of a
state supreme court actually using
politics claiming not based upon what
what cases come before you but actually
predetermining it talking about
redistricting talking about women's
rights going forward instead of looking
at a case by case and saying I'm going
to uphold the Constitution we've watched
money come from around the nation in
into this campaign you know what we
didn't sit back in the house we actually
participated in this as well Republicans
have to understand when we won the White
House we won Wisconsin so if you lose it
it's hard to win the White House back
you talk about winning the house yes
we've we're the only Republican entity
that have won the last two cycles in a
row we wish to have win by a larger
margin but the one thing I will tell you
is they don't give gavels out in small
medium and large we get the exact same
gavel and we're using it based upon the
Constitution each and every day and
we'll just figure up to these atrocities
wherever we see it I know you have to go
but one more question and um are you
confident that with ballot harvesting
and the push for earlier in earlier
voting all these election ballots that
are being mailed out applications for
ballots are you confident that the RNC
and the the political process for the
Republicans is going to be effective in
countering that and signing up people to
vote and getting them to the polls
well we better do it right I'll tell you
in California we have the worst election
law where they mail everybody about and
it's illegal to harvest but in that last
two election Cycles Republicans only one
we've taken six seats from the Democrats
in Congress so in other states they've
changed the election law remember what
they did in Georgia where the the
baseball actually left the All-Star game
but we had more people participate what
we need to be able to have happen we
need to make sure in America you have to
show an ID to vote we should need to
clean up our roles because in La you
have a about 1.2 million people on the
rolls who are not even old enough in the
process enough people there to be in
that we need to make sure that we have
elections that are fair and honest that
people can vote but we can make sure
that the elections are honest as they go
forward so we have to be cognates in
this but the one thing Republicans have
to understand we've got to stop this
idea that we're only going to vote on
Election Day if your state allows early
voting you need to vote early follow
your ballots as they go through and you
can trace them and that's something that
we have to wake up as as a party and not
lose these elections but win them for
the sake of the nation and the sake of
our Constitution and Mr Speaker the
number one issue for the voters do you
think will be the economy like as it was
with Reagan in 1980 it is
it is the economy if you watch what we
did on the house floor we made our
number one bill our HR one it's about
the economy lowering the price of energy
for all Americans it not only lowers the
price in America it lowers inflation it
lets people keep more of what they earn
and if you're caring about the
environment it'll lower Global emissions
if you took Russian natural gas away for
one year in Europe you would lower CO2
emissions by 218 million tons because
American natural gas is cleaner it also
creates America to be stronger the world
to be safer and the economy to be
stronger in America that's the
difference between Republicans and
Democrats you know what the Democrats
number one bill was when they were in
the majority to change election law to
worry about themselves we care about
Americans and we're bringing the issue
back to the economy and Pennsylvania
Arizona Wisconsin Michigan and yes
California have to make even more
progress there Mr speaker thank you very
much and uh fantastic meeting today
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else